this isn't incision me Oh God want to
atone megawatt oh and Omega verses in oh
no any raha Vina by Samoa
I'm Allah Allah tato ferret for America
decision
muga bana busy no no I thought the least
they could do was say you're queer sorry
this isn't going to happen
it's five o'clock in the morning in
southeastern Turkey ma Gabrielle is one
of the oldest Christian monasteries in
the world at first glance I seem to be
the only person here but I can hear
noises coming from inside the
monasteries church
they hold Messier every Sunday
I've come here to meet Petros he's one
of three young people my fellow
reporters and I will talk to during this
show
three young Christians who want to
devote their lives to their faith but
I'm not allowed to the people here as
suriani a tiny Orthodox Christian
minority loving and Muslim Turkey on
Ohio
enira Hawaiian embassy Mohammad Avila
tato ferret coronary 37 mu Gabbana
byzanium
an interim kono statement Farah
eleuterio de salón de segovia Madonna
but no there were young my furnace old
Dublin mr. Caruso
because I'm a woman I have to stand at
the back of the church together with the
nuns I feel like I've travelled back in
time
the suriani say the ritual stayed back
to the times of Jesus himself they even
speak Aramaic the same language Jesus
spoke
despite the rich history the suriani
don't enjoy the same rights as turkeys
muslim-majority they even face
oppression by the Turkish government
after the three-hour mess
I'm honored when the bishop the suriani
spiritual leader invites me over to talk
we don't have any rights in Turkey as
Christians we don't have anything and if
you don't have right to teach our
language to teach our religion to beat
any changes any anything for us for
ourselves so why what is the human
rights where is the democracy where is
one I don't know
Jaclyn knows about fighting for
something she believes him her biggest
dream is to become a Catholic priest
something that's forbidden by the church
because she's a woman
Jaclyn gives me a beginners lesson and
boxing both inside the ring and that
church she seems to enjoy challenging
people and breaking with tradition mr.
Stein at Leon
mr. Spock sensei on which his books are
attracted Serie A he included mine with
my colleague then since NAFTA
concentrates in earnest as garnish
himself in possession I can screw London
smoothest ization so as how in some
manner spot he nine talker so wishes how
a manicure I ain't talkin toughest to
being Muslim nor decision impossibly
Spivak mousse well that if ledge
detecting from manuals or best of
abilities as my cat ocean killer
Jaclyn moved from Germany to Switzerland
to get her master's degree in theology
her thesis is on the role of women in
the Catholic Church she's examining
whether women who want to be priests
could sue the church under
constitutional law
yes become of my period soon he had a
business
our concern is pollution scientists
academics and each Saturday mom okay as
to Kansas nice people analysis this
isn't in session me on God and when that
kind of snow got people turn on which
data as a mission ebook what when you're
the hope that God can care of hobby who
from Jaclyn didn't grow up in a
religious family her parents only went
to church at Christmas but as a teenager
Jaclyn felt that God was calling on her
she started going to church every week
and getting more involved in her parish
we can then open source under
consideration and van Doody was goofin
image-based become as a business so I'm
I'm doing this of I Madhava
so listen straighten the process or just
come out of country in inverted fashion
where's a sprint mmm healthy and this
isn't a fearless man even hot in the
field that's God I'm an escaped as a
sign of I'm victim an image rise in
demand also described we can our mission
fixed pumpkin manifest Giancana missile
Villavicencio Amazon can DC formal past
summer system may interfere
back at my gabrielle monastery for six
years
Petros lived here as a child monk from
an early age he learned a life of
discipline and rules
Petros shows me the classroom where he
spent every Saturday studying Aramaic
until he was 15 during the week the boys
irregular by semina honimaru hot right /
- really
same [ __ ] Oh Tyrone EW
just the hundred years ago most of the
people in this region where suriani
Christians I wonder how the people here
today deal with this Christian heritage
remember I mean not that I am so sorry
could should 4/3 high he was emitting
this year she is totally shocked
Sean excusive Yanni to our hi it's Jim
seshu and Oh detective Megan Abu took
channel - and ostrich builded a Sunni
Linda's now established each be in
London I will comedy be honest for the
Arab
I'm not much of a singer but I'm trying
my best to keep up I've come to this
church in downtown Chicago with M her
legal name is Marianne but she doesn't
go by that anymore the pastor here has
invited M to share her story four years
ago M came out as a lesbian but since
then she feels that doesn't really
describe her situation anymore she
doesn't see herself as a woman or a man
good morning it's such a pleasure to be
here to have the opportunity to worship
among you all this morning M grew up in
the United Methodist Church the second
biggest Protestant denomination in the
US I've struggled for a number of
reasons but certainly a big one has been
that I simultaneously love the United
Methodist Church and feel called to be a
minister in this church but I am also
unapologetically queer both of these
realities live so deeply in my bones
that I am incapable of giving up one for
the other the church has been retaining
women since the 1960s but practicing
homosexuals as the church calls them
can't become ministers I was told and I
knew also that there was zero percent
chance but just from a theological
spiritual perspective I really felt like
it was not my responsibility to refuse
myself from doing what I felt like I'm
supposed to do with my life
M has wanted to become a minister ever
since she was a teenager a few months
ago she moved to Chicago together with
her partner Ananda MN Ananda got married
a year ago they have a lot in common
Ananda also wants to be a minister her
church does allow gay and lesbian
pastors but it's still an uphill battle
the Presbyterian Church is ninety-six
percent why most of the pastor's are
male and most are straight so those odds
are really against me and in order for a
congregation to want a queer black
female pastor very very Sakhalin knows
the chances of her becoming a priest are
also slim to none she takes me to one of
her theology classes men and women are
here together to learn about the
scriptures but the professor doesn't
mention the inequalities in today's
church until I asked him after class
dust acacia wood / artist
I'm Sookie NAFTA found no design no
Hoover sieverts design for an unwitting
versus Edson on voter ID ask it is a
motion and so when our in enlightens
also enlightens competence that's one of
the death of until nine nine the Swedish
the doyen similars of not unknown even
avatar from the sphere resorts and hints
Aang would is most among and a motivator
and with the deserving the fish that has
to select a beneath the murky card
Jacklyn hopes she can make it possible
for women to become priests by writing
and talking about it but after my
conversation with her professor I'm
starting to see why there's so few
people like her willing to discuss the
topic openly yeah feeling um an
expensive profession has done better and
secure she loosened problem would become
as a flesh can and Shalom become
calculation Stallone on submit an Nathan
Lang Telugu studio owner and roof - day
notice Warren finish was King the 24
year old is willing to take the risk and
in case the church doesn't give her a
job
she says she might go into journalism
and cover stories about religion as a
reporter when she and her classmates go
out there is often a debate about
whether or not the church rules need
updating in order to be more compatible
with modern life and have some fun
yeah had the shaman steering angle
non-domestic and shine swishing the milk
is crystalline severe good am fine it's
really bad in half NIM remedy milk a
definite vet in mine mine Buddha says
even management plan in my head some
sense or look for a new convert our
uncie series of hair had more of a
medium risk level this is pleased to
meet her heart and Omid for me you have
fibers
and so looking Lady Gaga uses a lot of
religious mm came out while she was
still studying at a Seminary in Texas
she even started a community there to
support queer students on campus how did
the United Methodist Church treat you
during this time when you seek
coordination well I mean it changed a
lot over the eight years they started
off incredibly supportive but once I
came out it was a lot more ambiguous it
really depended on who I was talking to
and so my district committee in Austin
were incredible I mean they they ended
up getting in trouble because of their
support of me and official complaints
filed against them because they voted me
forward even though I had come out to
them m's case drew media attention the
Texas Church wanted to end her candidacy
before she even got to the final
interview but em sought legal advice and
rallied support on social media in the
end church officials were forced to put
it to a vote there were so many
conversations that were really offensive
that were being had publicly about what
so one of the big things was whether or
not people felt like they had enough
information to decide whether or not I'm
having sex and so there was official
discussion on whether or not I was
practicing that happened in a room of
400 clergy and so there were
conversations like that that are just
normalized in the Methodist Church that
are absolutely humiliating and
dehumanizing
I want to talk to United Methodist
ministers who support the official
policy what's their reasoning Reverend
Scott field is the senior pastor of a
big church west of Chicago 700 people
come to hear his sermons every Sunday he
shows me the Book of Discipline which
lays out the rules for everyone in the
United Methodist Church the practice of
homosexuality is incompatible with
Christian teaching therefore self-avowed
practicing homosexuals are not to be
certified as candidates ordained as
ministers or appointed to serve in the
United Methodist Church but to a gay
person this sounds pretty harsh do you
feel this is unjust what this statements
yeah no no I don't think so at all see
it has to do with what's the gospel and
and that's you know so there may be
different takes on this different
understandings but if the gospel is just
an affirmation of who I am let's say
that I'm a particularly Randy or
promiscuous heterosexual has nothing to
do with being gay or lesbian well the
church has some rules about that too it
says to me that maybe the way you used
to be but if you're a follower of Jesus
you have to change your sexual behavior
to me it just seems unfair Reverend
Scott can be married to his wife and be
a minister but em has to choose
I go to visit Petrus and his family at
their home in a small Christian village
the family lives off the land selling
some of their crops to make a little
money when I come they've all put on
their best clothing for my visit
Petra's parents are proud that their
family has managed to stay here
Martina was a lady named Josie - mama -
oh honey oh I could you Marcus Dempsey
who is working no holiday Murphy nahuatl
telenovela botamo
among misfire killing 20 year Petros and
his eight siblings all lived together
with their family in this farmhouse
Bobby how hot male only [ __ ] no
dog or Oh Cabana band amid a guarantee
Behav Oh buzzer oh no tree as notable
behavioral Roy hey Jana do Goro Laker
body Yanni or the toy for South Korea
Cubano Goron LuAnn for now Petros works
on the farm it's unclear what the future
holds for him he wants to study
Christian theology but the universities
in Turkey don't offer it he also wants
to escape poverty that either means
marrying a girl from another country are
going to live in a monastery
we set up for the Turkish city of Medina
the deputy mayor there is the suriani
like Petros
Petros hopes she can give him some
advice since he wants a future here in
Turkey in the last century millions of
suriani have been forced to leave their
homes there are only 24 thousand left in
Turkey a quarter of a million suriani
fled to Europe over 400,000 to the US we
pass by a refugee camp thousands of
people have come here from nearby Syria
to escape the terrorist group Islamic
state we finally arrived in the Turkish
city Medina
Petra's nervous about our meeting he
wants to ask the deputy mayor why it
isn't possible for him to study
Christian theology at the University
here in Turkey
even though the country's Constitution
guarantees freedom of religion the
reality is quite different a close I'm
shelling and Madonna Madonna Clem Selena
Ali no shade like Bella new clothes I'm
Hanna a la mode de la novia name was
here why Holland Quixote frozen for Hina
and Adela Jen you made a no get over you
Petros are surprised by her response
enjoy business a winner
Mama's Uzi whichever come and see the
show you nothing to tell you my theory I
hope someday I'll get to come back here
I'm curious to see if Petros can improve
his situation and live his dream
for now this is the closest Jaclyn can
get to her dream we've come from
Switzerland to a church in Austria where
she has found a priest who supports her
ambitions
today she gets to help leap three
morning services
that's very ear tuned vanillish heart
I'm in the urine
I will give you des it's tarin schnell
at least probably my own song of before
her not garnish but act one detriment
I'm hurting FNG dominantly now for
inflation problem cut Gibson and Union
and in concrete an Afrikaans act math it
was the house I'm curious to see how
people at the church reactor
Jacqueline's participation in the mass
there's a fingers co-efficient versus of
almost it says the coalition here
scooter - the yellow flower and ago
cocktail parties in your face
macrophylla an oil furnace router
straightening absolute niche to see
France in talk mange
speaker fittest niche distinct at Orakei
in over Enrique Onan so for sure hope
miss until honest the scary Atticus race
Lama came in the stirred us first we had
second master's in education oh it's
come to my often fought off an escaped
father isn't a conservative traditional
language dealt the machine than a
Finnish tests and if how it worked
the vitalism conceived the Antikythera
voice which is a condition would have
come on cloud service a plane would of
active in kata since mr. clean even
helps baptize a baby but in the long run
she doesn't want to just help out she
wants to be upfront at the altar serving
God
Jaclyn believes in changing the church
from within she knows she has a long
road ahead of her and that big changes
don't happen in the church overnight
em is waiting for the day her church
will change as well in the end she did
get her interview in Texas but the
ordination committee rejected her saying
they had doubts about her inner calling
as a minister they didn't once mention
her sexuality in Chicago M has found a
new spiritual home the United Methodist
Church that accepts her as she is with
pastors who support her after all she's
been through she still wants to become a
minister in the church she's known all
her life why do you think is it
important for you to keep pursuing
ordination well there are plenty of
other LGBT people in this church and
there are LGBT youth and LGBT children
growing up right now I'm being told that
they're they're incompatible with
Christian teaching and so it's important
to me as long as I can to keep pushing
back against a church that's harming the
people that are growing up in this
church I want them to see queer pastors
I want them to know they can be a pastor
- I mean I want them to know that the
church is a place that should embrace
them and affirm them and they should be
able to be whoever they are
M and Ananda continued to fight for
their dream and someday I hope to see
them in the pulpit
you